wow jésus qu'est-ce que l'enfer mec toujours sous
contrôle pas de sentiments de rage écrasants
non une quantité normale de rage vous
revenez à la génération 4 quand vous dormez était le
klaxon à air vraiment nécessaire pour la comédie
absolument c'est un voyage de plusieurs années que vous êtes
sur le point  se lancer dans
qui est ton meilleur ami nikki
spandex
spandex est ton meilleur ami
être un hulk demande un équilibre
[musique]
tu as tellement plus à apprendre
oui
donc je suis clairement en train de le clouer à toutes ces
choses
si tu veux retourner  la vie d'
avocat je respecte le fait
qu'il ne veut pas dire que de
plus en plus de surhumains excentriques
sortent de la menuiserie
nous allons lancer une division pour
eux et je veux que la she-hulk soit le
visage de
jennifer wallace
namaste
j'ai  un sérieux conflit d'intérêts
cet homme a essayé de tuer mon cousin bruce
ouais c'est tout à fait bien oh
[Musique] les
gens s'en soucient seulement parce que je
représente emil blonsky je pense qu'ils s'en
soucient parce qu'ils sont comme hé cette
fille est verte
fais ton truc dieu je  vraiment  comme cette
tenue
je ne suis pas fier de cette
mademoiselle walters nous avons répondu à une
puissance supérieure notre univers est au bord d'un
précipice
je suis avocat
nous faisons les choses selon le livre
le livre du bidonville non le livre des
lois américaines euh
si  tu aimes ça ou pas tu es maintenant un
super
-héros faisons ça
tu sais que cet ami que tu avais au lycée
qui était bien plus cool que tu n'étais
attirant a attiré toute l'attention de
tout le monde
[Musique]
bonjour
je pense que je suis jaloux c'est quoi  je te
sens
[Musique]